ne participez pas à ça s'il vous plaît
et ne laissait pas penser à vos abonnés
que c'est normal qu'ils participaient
pas ce qu'est a dit sa nacre ou non qui
a dit ça donc
c'est pas un artiste ne participe à
achat sa s'il vous plaît les réalités
télé réalité est-ce que ça sur canal +
time again and quoi parce que c'était
sur canal+ aucune idée nabila non non
c'est quelqu'un qui est utile mais je
suis un homme ou une femme mimi mathy
non-match à aider sur les réseaux et les
eaux comment et les au québec c'est
l'animatrice journal du hard non non
et non non c'est un truc assez engagés
doivent s'engager en tout cas un peu
engagés pour une couse une corrigé par
la cause animale
hugo clément bravo
il a clashé ryan belle cité sur une
vidéo de lui dans une cage face à un
ours récupérant une guimauve
regardez voilà la capture d'écran gap et
rennes bensetti voilà c'est pour un film
il a dit cheikh réel bensetti c'est tout
ce que vous nourrissez avec un chamallow
passe sa vie enfermé dans des petits
espaces et contraint d'effectuer des
numéros contre nature pour amuser le
public ne participez pas à ça s'il vous
plaît et le lendemain un bar et une
batte city qui s'est un petit peu un
petit peu agacé qui était un peu vexé il
a répondu ça cette petite vidéo pour
répondre aux messages que j'ai reçus
concernant l'ours
bon déjà calme loin calme en eau parce
qu à vous entendre on dirait que je
m'appelle van pelt que je suis au kenya
que je chasse le lion et je le mets
entre autres dans le salon qu'allemande
on en train de faire un film c'est du
cinéma
où on fait évader un ours dans cirque
l'ours ne tourne que 45 minutes par jour
il a trois jours de tournage sur trois
mois là les gens qui me connaissent
savent très bien quel point j'aime les
animaux et à quel point je suis contre
la maltraitance et d'une manière
[Applaudissements]
clément doit évidemment quoi qu'il
arrive c'est exceptionnel sur hugo clés
rouge non mais franc du collier
complètement tout le temps notons que
jamais mais je suis d'accord c'est en
opportuniste mais pourquoi non c'est sûr
mais ken gracey lui qui a pu des
limousins fort boyard c'est grâce à lui
qu'il ya plus d'élément dans l'excès non
c'est pas grâce à lui à demi plein de
gens qui s'intéressent à la cause
animale avant hugo clément il vient il
réquisitionne est en vie abba you go
clément fait tous nos égos que la grâce
et les abattoirs et pinceaux tourte on
mélange tout de quoi on est en train
d'enlever les animaux absolument partout
ça ne nécessite quelques affinements
plus de nuances que ça je suis désolé ça
la cause animale depuis ma naissance
il ya longtemps c'est à dire
une espèce d'intégrisme maintenant qui
fait qu'on mélange tous les animaux
imprégné on peut pas les recaser là
comme ça n'importe où ils sont nés en
captivité et hugot clément je suis
désolé je les aime bien mais il l'est
s'intéressent à la cause animale depuis
relativement peu de temps par rapport à
plein d'autres dont on parle moins que
je trouve plus sincères mais s'ils sont
nés en captivité c'est que déjà l'être
humain a fait quelque chose de pas
normal et ravage la normale en ce moment
la ville oursel soit extraordinaire
comme les animaux dans les parcs marins
les orques les dauphins voyez d'evry
alors que florian venir pour revenir à
hugo clément parce qu'on parle de lui
j'ai interviewé alexandra rosenfeld
cette semaine qui est sa compagne damman
très très fiers nous hisser le soutien
mais ça file souligne que d'isabelle
c'est à dire qu'il est très clivant
c'est à dire qu'il reçoit autant de
messages positifs de soutien que deux
messages très agressif donc c'est pas
quelqu'un qui fait l'unanimité oui mais
moi je m'élève envers lui c'est parce
que j'ai dit mais oui je les cuis vont
maintenant qu'il ya plein de gens qui le
font avec plus de discrétion va mais
pour moi en avant et que je donc plus
profondément au temps
mais le shérif et la forme de fichiers
comme ça sur instagram est lui de lui
tacle entre guillemets la honte en un
peu démago oui voilà c'était par des
salades des clubs comme un coq comment
comment on fait avancer une cause sur ce
qu'on trouve pas servi mes blagues
auxquelles sont attachés des mains tu
vois hugot clément et tous les autres
derrière
jean michel ruiz m mais c'est la porte
et a pas cracher sur sur bourvil ou de
funès qu'ils ont fait la vache et le
prisonnier bas la bâche aussi tous les
jours on va traîner au bout d'une corde
c'est pareil chez les animaux dans le
cinéma ils sont très bien traités cm x
de calais - les journaux cet homme est
un exemple suis là
juste un truc ce que tu reproches à hugo
clément ça s'appelle le charisme ça veut
dire qu'il ya
des causes qui sont rendus que ce soit
celle là ou un autre par richard vivre
et de temps en temps il ya quelqu'un qui
sort du lot et il se trouve que la cei
bouclant pdci qui l'aimé pas c'est
d'autant super qui fait si les
superstitions cci mais ce qu'il fait
mais du coup ça met dedans je suis bien
s'engueuler je trouve qu'ils se
mettraient en avant par rapport à
l'alcool ils m'ont dit c'est normal
aujourd'hui si je peux me permettre pour
des causes importantes comme celle là si
on fait les choses de façon mesurée
qu'on avance sur la pointe des pieds
qu'on est là qu'on fait on arrondit les
angles ça n'avance pas il ya un moment
où si on veut faire bouger les choses
faut faire comme hugot clément une voix
qui porte et faut taper fort c'est comme
ça qu'on fait avancer les causes sinon
il se passe rien si ça avançait autant
tu lis il était aussi efficacement les
routes regarde on va s'adapter au mieux
et c'est nous les bouches toutes les
ruines mais c'est lui + les puces lui
c'est comme ça que donatella soit on en
parle maintenant et que maintenant
produire les abattoirs fait comme sa
capitale où nous donner dans fort boyard
rien avant hugo clément et on a
vraiment en moi parce que tu en fais un
super semaine sur lui on s'en fout de
lui il fait avancer la cause animale et
paris vous adorez and then chikli mais
oui battu en 1 ou dans une case qui
demande à sa maman oui j'y peux pas être
heureux bah oui les relations sont pas
masquer go clément l'une des faces
pardon mais c'est cool que maudit pas
personnel c'est un truc
il a fait un legs c'est un truc qui
zappe à rigaud clément est un porte
parole du mal à dix mois des noms que
tout le
monde écoute de fines nouvelle prise à
aller relativement vite
passent à la barre pour parler à face
aux politiques donc c'est qu'il a une
crédibilité mais tout a une crédibilité
un peu plus important de voies peut-être
que c'est de l'opportunisme et de nos
porteurs n'ont même pas aussi peut-être
qu'il sait débat tient ça ça va faire en
sorte que la répartir du long et puis
pardon il était dans quotidien très bien
payé il n'est pas besoin d'en sortir
pour aller sur un os
à la cause est ce que ça ne dessert pas
sa cause quand il s'attaque à ryan
bensetti parce qu'il sait très bien ce
qui fait le mec il fait de la com en
faisant ça il sait qu'on va tous en
parler et ça moi je trouve que ça
dessert sa cause parce que c'est
anecdotique et la réponse de ryan
bensetti est très bonne mais c'est une
attaque c'est une attaque cas pas lieu
d'être et les pavots n'est tombé malade
mais vous vous êtes des malades un patch
il cherche pas de garanties gentiment
c'est parce que tu fais c'est un ours
que dans une carrière j'ai dit gentiment
été malgré tout lui donner à ma
chamallows il n'est pas fait pour ça
alors que pointent la cdm miled chez
accor est gentiment il n'a pas été
agressée il a dit quand même est
fait pour ça c'est de la com la phlébite
bien-être aux animaux jamais fait de la
com et il a trouvé cette sénat politique
à la c'est la première fois que
je ne comprends pas comment tu peux dire
ça parce que moi je le vivais ça c'est
comme si tu me disais que tu donnes 10
euros un taux chars dans la rue tu dis
bah voila tu fais ça pour toi pour ta
bonne conscience on s'en fout tu as
donné d euros un peu genre tabac c'est
un règne un bon chercheur g
photo fm après les rendre le rendu est
moins efficace bon si tu veux ça me suis
tu vas voir forme et qu'il ya des
dizaines d'enfants cependant le pire et
mixtes avec des chamallows recherchons
les ours pour leur donne à manger comme
ça c'est terrible mais on a perdu deux
fois
on
va vous séparer parce que ça devient un
fardeau pour deux séries mais c'est un
peu compliqué